The joe rogan experience and age,
live body George and learn how to fight.
Oh right.
I thought what Brian did play football
this whole time.
She's a Swat team is
Lebron James Basketball,
but sports is whatever Tom tells me.
If you don't watch anything outside of
that.
No,
I like tennis.
I used to watch like ladies golf.
Do you stick
that she isn't gay?
Is that the case that I've heard that
said before?
What's that ladies?
Golf is like a lot of k checks.
I think there's a little bit of a port.
100% of course.
Always do.
Look at the sticks.
They is.
There's definitely,
there's trying today.
There's definitely loves angry Twitter.
That's what it is.
I don't know who watches ladies' golf.
I'm not sure what they are amazing
golfers that are golfers essentially
just a bunch of Lesbos.
Yeah.
It's amazing how good they are though.
Fuck man.
Well,
it's one of the few groups that lesbians
available to really grow like lesbians
can't,
they have a hard time getting a
community.
You know,
like gay dudes have massive communities
all over the country,
like parts of the tenderloin.
And if you go to the Santa Monica area,
West Hollywood,
Santa Monica Boulevard area,
there are dates they've,
they've,
they've all conglomerated,
they know where the party's at.
The but then fucking that place on
Hollywood boulevard,
the West on Santa Monica Boulevard,
West Hollywood spot.
That is the gay spot on earth,
that area,
that whole area while you're driving.
Know Santa Monica,
is that club rage still there?
That's the flagship club because that's
the one that's on the big,
that was the one that,
you know,
we're doe Haney is W I was coming down
don't uni and I'm at the red light there
and it was a Saturday night and it was
fucking beautiful weather and everybody
was out and it was a gay party on the
streets,
man.
And there was these two dudes and they
both have their hands,
their fingers looped into each other's
belt loops.
And they were like in a lot,
cause I kinda scissoring and just
grinding Dick's together.
I can only wash us a certain amount of
time before some days slips and I gotta
get Outta here like this.
It was,
it was like a fucking bomb had been
ignited and I had to get outside of the
blast radius [inaudible] happy as fuck a
bear bar in silver lake,
so you'd have to walk past the bear bar.
The best trader Joe.
Whoa,
that's a specific type of gay bar.
Tuesday nights is like rim job.
Tuesdays at the big sign out front,
it's rem job Tuesdays
and
you'd hear like you drive by,
you can have be having like the like the
most quiet,
lame kind of night and you're like,
there's nothing going on.
And then as you pulled up you're like,
Ooh.
You're like,
oh,
there's the Dick's grinding and like
you're like,
ah,
neighborhood is alive right now.
And the best part there was a security
guard that would stand out.
Oh yeah.
Because he was in front of a gay bar.
You didn't know if it was just a
costume.
The first few times I was going on out
tonight and he's like,
no,
I'm just [inaudible].
He had a mustache
mustache.
Very few.
The pull off the John Stossel sick upper
must commit to that.
That's strange.
That's how I was wondering that because
people usually mock the mustache,
you know,
are they rock the ironic mustache,
but in the gay community it's like,
Yo,
I'm down for you.
I saw a guy the other day,
it was beautiful.
He had timberlands on and yet cutoff
Jean shorts and he had like,
uh,
like uh,
one of those leather scally caps on and
he had a Jean jacket that was
sleeveless.
Nice.
He was fucking dictate.
This was like right after I worked in
San Francisco,
San Francisco with Greg Fitzsimmons.
Greg Fitzsimmons fucking killed me.
He got on stage and he goes,
this is the last city where there's real
faggots [inaudible] leather pants and a
handlebar mustache.
Oh my God.
Are you fucking crushed too?
Cause it was so true on a bashed
animals.
Yeah.
That's fucking funny.
That guy that you described,
like if,
if,
if cock was a company that's the
chairman and CEO of cock in charge with
the fluffy socks,
you know the style.
Yeah.
Scrunched down and the timberlands like
open.
And then he's got cutoff Jean shorts and
a Jean Jacket.
He's so gay.
Sleeveless,
San Francisco.
This was this one,
Santa Monica.
Yeah.
This one,
the gas guy on earth.
The only one that comes close to him.
I was in Houston once and I wanted to
congratulate this guy the way he was
rocking it,
but I didn't want to offend them.
I let it go.
He had leg warmers on that.
We're rainbow that's already covered leg
warmers on.
And he had these little designer like
they looked like some odd tennis shoe
type thing that he was wearing,
some very trendy tennis shoe.
And then he had these boys gym shorts.
He's board member.
Those gym shorts used to wear your blue
with the white stripe and they were way
too small and they were way too small.
Okay.
And he's our frail man as it is.
And then he had a pink skin,
tight shirt and a some crazy
multicolored Bandana.
And as he was working out,
he's working out like this.
Ah,
AH,
like grunting
legwarmers man,
man that's ever walked the face of the
earth.
This guy,
if he got together with the other guy,
they would create a black hole.
Homosexuality.
Yeah.
It would eat its way through the cement.
Eat Cement,
spit,
come back at you.
It would be a sinkhole of gay.
If he slipped and fell into it.
You'd fall,
fall prey to the game.
You saw something.
She lives in San Francisco that you
definitely saw.
The is thing that you can see during
the,
you said during the parade one time you
saw a guy fucking on the corner on the
street,
just on the street.
I mean saying guys,
if you see guys but fucking on the
street,
you'd be like,
that's the gay straight up.
You'll never forget that street at that
moment.
It's one of the gas streets on her.
A short,
I think it was during the Folsom street
fair
game.
Mardi gras.
That's when I fucked on the street.
I like to limit it to fairs.
Bring your kids if you're willing to
fuck on the street during a fair,
you're a real gangster.
Like you're out there just fucking,
you're a part of the problem.
The Bear Jim in our old neighborhood,
some guys,
so this thing
is they,
these big guys,
they also like to build their Musk.
Yes.
And that's another part of it.
And Tommy,
one time I would think you were downwind
of a guy.
The fan was behind him or something.
Fuck man.
And you could smell his was like,
it was so strong.
It wasn't like Jim smells strong.
It was like a personal body odor that
you know,
you can just tell when someone's bos
kicking,
kicking because he was dirty.
Washed it.
Yeah,
it was.
It was a definitely a,
I haven't showered in like in a while.
Maybe it's to ward off the smell of shit
while you're fucking,
you ever think about that?
I mean there's gotta be something in
such a pride.
He had such pride about his Musk.
I could just tell like the way he was
like you picking up what I'm putting out
there right now.
You look about them,
but
I imagine that some people were walking
through the gym that day.
Like,
thanks brother.
Thanks for putting this out here because
you got me fired up to get me ready to
do some squats.
Yeah,
there's different levels of like gay
guys to write,
but what they're into,
like some guys are just into other like
crazy big gay guys and some guys they're
like twinks,
they're like little tiny little bowl.
Yeah.
There was this dude that I shave it down
brother,
but I knew that was a producer type
character.
So wealthy character always had like
these young boys with him.
They were always like just 20 years old.
A little confused.
Like that's,
you know,
a well known comic or like one.
Why do you only know why?
Yeah,
that's true.
I know several,
yeah,
that's sort of a,
that's kind of a type
we'll otters,
what's an honor?
It's a tall,
slender.
Hairless is an auditor as opposed to a
big hairy fat,
which is a bear.
And a younger bear is actually a cub
bears go with cubs and cubs are just
smaller and more.
Now I heard that the word Twinkies
coming taboo toy,
that bag is kind of not cool to say.
I think twink is starting to become,
everybody's fired up about,
well here's what happened.
So you know,
Andy Cohen on Bravo,
I think he went on some other show and
he's like,
oh look at all these twinks here.
And then the twin community got really
upset and started doing it.
And so he apologized.
He apologized to the twinks.
Everybody is looking for an opportunity
to be sensitive.
We are in such a weird time.
It is,
it's like people have found reward in
like pointing at like hot button,
things like that.
Like,
Hey,
you know,
at the twin community we do not,
who else is fucking super annoying and
like this,
I mean this one's way different level of
like how fucking what assholes they are.
Is this like 1 million moms?
It's just like we're mothers that are
Christian that want to raise the fucking
like great kids and like,
but we're complete politically bigoted,
uh,
discriminatory assholes.
They publicly lash out for the,
this is like the second or third time at
JC Penny for having Ellen to generous
after spokesman.
They're like,
you realize that none of us are ever
going to shop there again because you
hired Ellen to be like that kind of
shit.
Like,
and they got really mad about her latest
Christmas commercial with Elvis and
they're like,
you have a fucking a gay woman with
Elvis.
What's gonna fucking happen next?
Like,
hey,
that's a good point.
I mean,
what?
What happened?
What will happen next?
Ins and Ian's mixing up with magical
creatures.
That's shit.
Shit crazy.
Definitely develop some ways.
They have nefarious intention,
so they developed some sort of lesbian
pixie dust sprayed over a city when
they're flying around and your kids,
because
we've got a bunch of miniature gay elves
running around.
Listen man,
you mock
the lesbian community have these genres.
I don't know.
Yeah.
They have lipstick,
lesbian,
Fred Flinstone looking lesbian lipsticks
to,
that's right.
Yeah.
The lipsticks is
100% yet the other ones are,
especially if they want to fight,
but not always good at shows either.
Didn't want to argue with best.
It's like humor can be cool for me.
They can be cool.
It's like you can't really generalize a
whole fucking sexual orientation is,
yeah.
I've met a lot of cool lesbians,
straight people to
God dammit.
That's true.
That's sort of the anti positive
approach.
Everybody's got their own special gift.
Everybody sucks their own way
to the dark place trail.
That's hilarious.
And so true.
Okay.